first of all let's start off with movies
are you big mob movie guy or know some
of them yes dinero did anything with De
Niro yeah if I give you some names can
you just tell me if you you know what
kind of reaction you had to the movies
Bugsy did you watch Bugsy I did would
you think about it it was okay that was
already what I was a Hollywood movie
didn't do anything
yeah how about black mass I didn't see
that one
that's the Johnny Depp why yeah watch
that okay how about Goodfellas I liked
it yeah it was great pretty accurate I
have a story your life was like yep
Godfather a Hollywood movie really yeah
you're not a big Godfather no I am I
think it was a great it's a great movie
there's a depict of life this yeah it
does it does is that the closest one I
think either Goodfellas would be closer
Goodfellas would be closer than your
father yeah interesting
how about Donnie Brasco Donnie Brasco
was okay it was alright Jim ever have
any dealing with Joe Pistone ER now
never
okay how about Scarface with Al Pacino
yeah I like Al Pacino but it was okay
them kind of movies in casino you know
in like I'd like that one a lot
Oscar : improv Retiro you have any
dealings with Oscar Goodman no just that
he represented me also he did represent
you yes good experience no not really
yeah I mean one day he came to court
with a big cut over his eye Quist they
were drunk the night before in the
saloon and they felled then he fell down
and slit his eye lid on the on the curve
they were having a good time any dealing
with Tony Spilotro or now no okay
how about Once Upon a Time in America
that was good I enjoyed that movie one
of my dad's favorite Bronx Tale I
enjoyed that too good one yeah Carlito's
Way it was that was it okay
how about mobsters with Christian Slater
no Michael asked you is this story he
said no that wasn't my earliest so
you're number one would be Goodfellas
yeah yeah I like the films did you watch
Irish Man I did would you think about it
it was a good movie but it's not true
it's not true no at all that guy didn't
know Frank Sheeran didn't kill all them
people how how confident are you about
the fact that he's very confident
from Philadelphia's a union guy probably
a tough guy beat guys up that are
straight you know one strikes and all
the union but he was in the killer he
was a note I mean why did the mob why
did we have to hire him to kill or kill
people and they actually I think in the
movie they actually paid him which you
don't get paid when you kill people in
the mob you're not on the payroll if
you're given an assignment you just do
you do it is not a bonus for it
ya know I mean you have your own
business but no was it frustrating
watching like you're like I know for a
fact this isn't true or did you just
kind of like what select an arrow okay I
liked all them guys in it was big it was
really good like Joe Pesci it was great
and by the way several people have also
said the same thing you said about the
fact that you know there was not much
truth behind it
[Music]